are you doing I lost my baby face Oh
[Music]
having a baby face I feel like I've
never been treated my age even though
I'm going to turn 30 next year for a
while I even had hashtag baby face
problems trending on my social media
page just because the situation's were
so ridiculous it was kind of hilarious a
lot of people say oh you're so lucky but
when you're constantly being told you
look underage because you said that I
looked Oh getting your ID checked look
at a two o'clock moonlight Sherman City
room y'all ready yeah I'd let you look
down to me yeah I'm almost 30 actually
okay y'all running an errand and getting
your cheeks pinched all the time
it's really hard to feel that way I feel
like looking younger a lot of people
don't take me seriously so I want to see
what it's like when society actually
views you as an adult
[Music]
haha oh wow
that's me but whoa yeah I definitely
look older Wow
look like my dad my face is a lot older
but my style is a little younger so I
think I'm gonna go for all my grown-up
clothes and see how everybody else
thinks of this oh hey any you there's no
what we enjoy you like just a lot more
crusty you chisel look just like
sophisticated hold on okay late 30s
early 40s ugly in my fifties oh and you
think I know what you can tell me you're
15 or 35 I took those mixer what
apparently my co-workers were a little
bit thrown off by this but I'm gonna see
how society treats me a little bit
differently with this space
I forgot it
so getting Carlos wasn't as exciting as
I thought it was and I kind of started
missing my own face by the end of it
such a good thing I like the face that
you have don't get it I honestly prefer
to keep my baby face I mean I've got
time to go into it
she found of the baby face right today
yeah don't change yourself no one should
change themselves I think I was just
envious of the grass on the other side
of the hill but once I kind of frolicked
in that grass I was I was over it plus I
got my cheeks pinched anyways oh my god
[Music]